we are going to look today at one of the
most remarkable pieces of video that i
have ever seen in the entire time i have
been doing this show
and you all know we've seen a lot of
outrageous video in the middle of alex
jones defamation trial it is the award
phase during which a jury is to decide
how much money should the plaintiffs get
for having been defamed by infowars
conspiracy theorist alex jones
it was revealed that alex jones own
incompetent lawyer
sent a digital copy of all of alex jones
text messages and phone communications
to the plaintiff's lawyers i really need
people to understand how insane this is
alex jones for the last 10 12 14 days
however long this phase of the trial has
been going on
has been
lying
and making claims like i never did any
texting about sandy hook which is the
subject matter of the defamation trial
and all along the plaintiff's council
had
knowledge
that alex jones was lying
he did text about sandy hook and the
reason the lawyer knew it is alex jones
lawyer mistakenly sent him all of the
records
and yesterday during the trial it came
out this video going instantly viral
do you know what perjury is
becoming the line of the day you have to
see this
so you did get my text messages
and they said you didn't nice trick
yes mr johnson indeed yes mr jones
indeed
you didn't give this text message to me
you don't you don't know where this came
from do you know where i got this no
mr jones
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed did not take any steps to
identify it as privileged or protected
in any way
and as of two days ago it fell free and
clear into my possession this is this is
one of the best things that has ever
happened during a trial i've seen that
is how i know you lied to me when you
said you didn't have text messages
and this is the moment that alex jones
soul leaves his body you can see it exit
at the 47 second mark in this video
did you know that
i see i told you the truth this is your
perry mesa moment i gave them my phone
and then mr jones you need to answer the
question
no i don't know this happened but i mean
i told you i gave him a phone over and
just said no
you said in your deposition
you searched your phone
you said you pulled down the text did
the certain function for sandy hook
that's what you said mr jones correct
and i had several several different
phones with this number but i did yeah
i mean that's why you got it
the pretzel that alex jones is twisting
himself into is really something else
here
my lawyer sent it to you but i'm hiding
it okay
mr jones
mr joseph just answered questions
there's no question
mr benson also only asked questions sure
mr jones in discovery you were asked do
you have sandy hook text messages on
your phone and you said no correct
you said that under oath
didn't you i mean i was mistaken i was
mistaken but you've got the messages
right there you know what perjury is
saying
i just want to make sure you know before
we go any further you know what it is
yes i do i mean i'm not a tech guy i
told you i gave in my testimony the
phone to the lawyers before whatever and
and so you've got my phone but we didn't
give it to you no mr jones one more time
and please remember if you need to
assert that amendment you can't i need
to know that you can do that
but you test them
if you need to plead the fifth here then
you're able to do that which of course i
mean it's a strategy as well because
that if all of a sudden he asserts the
fifth amendment even though of course
strictly speaking that cannot be used in
order to indicate guilt or
responsibility it's certainly not going
to look very good i have no idea how
plaintiff's council
did not
i don't know how plaintiff's council was
able to go two weeks
without
the biggest s eating grin on his face as
alex jones tells lie after lie
knowing that he has the records already
he waited until the perfect moment and
he dropped it like he had been planning
this his entire life
it's very difficult to imagine a more
humiliating and public implosion than
this
and then also during during yesterday's
uh testimony
um alex jones was confronted about the
fact that during the trial he's been
broadcasting images of the judge on fire
and that's also just another incredible
moment look at this
the person on the left of this image is
our judge correct
yes the person on the right is another
judge you don't like right yes okay
one of the things you
think one of the things you've been
talking about a lot recently on your
show
even within the past couple months
is your allegation
that government officials
are aiding in pedophilia child
trafficking and the grooming of children
he's basically being confronted with
pizzagate as applied to the judge in a
court of law while under oath
what do you mean like what jeffrey
epstein did with cleanse sure if that's
a yes is that a yes yes okay
and on thursday
you and infowars started connecting
those allegations to our judge didn't
you
no
in fact mr jones you're telling the
world
not to believe
what happens in this courtroom
because the judge
worked with child protective services
who you say
is involved with pedophilia and child
trafficking correct not all of it but
it's the texas youth commission got
caught doing it a lot there's been a lot
of that here i'm not asking you that mr
jones i'm asking you you're telling
imagine if every time these right-wing
nuts lied
they were subjected to under oath
cross-examination of their claims i mean
trump would have no campaign the world
not to believe what's happened in this
trial
because this judge
is involved with cps who is working with
child traffickers in pedophilia correct
by the way if you're not watching
the look on the judge's face as alex
jones is being questioned about his
claims about this very judge i have
never seen anything like this no that's
not what i'm saying okay your honor at
this time we would like to show a clip
from mr jones show on thursday where
those words are saying
foreign all right so now they get into
you know alex jones lawyer tries to
exclude the video that they want to play
and ultimately they do play it this is
unlike anything i have ever seen a
massive public humiliation for alex
jones and in this next segment we are
going to look at when the subject of the
money finally comes up
one of our long longtime sponsors is
monk pack the keto friendly granola bars
and nut and seed bars i keep these
stocked in my pantry all the time the
texture is great the sweet gooey
goodness is fantastic but each bar has
only one gram of sugar or less just two
to three net carbs and under 150
calories my favorite lately has been sea
salt dark chocolate people know about my
love affair with dark chocolate but you
can also get other flavors like caramel
sea salt peanut butter dark chocolate
and others then you've got the monk pack
granola bars in flavors like coconut
cocoa chip blueberry almond and honey
nut i don't do keto myself but they are
a great on-the-go snack if you love
something sweet and delicious but
without the sugar which is what i'm
going for they just hit the spot and if
you don't love monk pack as much as i do
they'll refund all of your money just
email them my audience gets 20 off your
first purchase at monkpack.com
when you use the coupon code pacman at
checkout the link is down below